Amazing.
I think we can get started here. How is
the conference so far?
>> Amazing. Yeah, I I think Gaddy and team
did a fabulous job. Really is
great.
So, um my name is Andre. I've been in
cyber security for actually more than
three decades. uh I wrote one of the
original anti virus engines in the 90
1990s and as you can imagine I've been
to many many security conferences when
it comes to vulnerabilities and
vulnerability research I think the
pattern has always been very familiar
very much the same like uh a researcher
would be on the stage kind of say here
is what we found here is the clever
trick that we used to find this uh here
is what it means and um thank you very
much round of applause and see you next
year. And so um this talk is going to be
slightly different even though we do
have some real findings, we do have some
discoveries uh but the point really is
not that much about the research itself.
It is about the engine that actually
allowed us to make those findings. And
um I think the the theme the overarching
subject uh today and tomorrow at this
conference and many conferences 2025 and
surely in 2026 are going to be how AI is
changing this landscape uh quite
dramatically now with the ability to
reason to somehow take into account
context and to perhaps go much faster
and at scale and potentially even at the
depth uh that humans typically didn't
have. So I think it's quite amazing and
uh but it's not just security. If you
think about you know the 2024 I think
Nobel prizes everyone kind of raised
their eyebrows with the Nobel prizes in
both physics and chemistry being granted
not to physicist or chemists but to AI
people to Jeff Hinton and Deis Hassabis.
Uh and so I think what we are seeing
here is kind of a logical uh sort of um
fallout of that as well. the AI engines
being super uh super great at many of
these things. So when it comes to
vulnerability research and finding
vulnerabilities through AI engines,
obviously this is not a new idea. So we
heard from Heather herself in the
morning about deep uh um project nap
time at Google which started kind of
really funny name like security
researchers spending sleepless nights uh
with uh all the let's say uh reverse
engineering and fuzzing tools uh and
then they figured maybe AI could take a
shift as well and they could get some
sleep and that evolved into something
that they call big sleep which obviously
was kind of much longer autonomous
systems that could do the same thing. Uh
then some of you may be familiar with AI
cyber challenge that was a joint project
of of DARPA and ARPA age that started
2023. It was a two-year program. Uh 42
teams enrolled. Uh then, you know,
progressed to semi-finals and then
ultimately to finals last year at Defcon
uh where the winning teams were
announced. And to me uh the most
fascinating thing was the amount of the
speed of change in which the teams moved
through that competition. If you
remember in the semi-final round which
is DEFCON 2024 only about 35% of all the
planted vulnerabilities were found. Uh
so more than 2/3 were never identified
by none of the teams. One year later in
2025 at the final round 87% of all the
vulnerabilities were found. So it's a
massive massive improvement. These were
only seven teams. remember there were
also a lot of restrictions as well like
they had limited amount of tokens that
they could use etc. But really amazing
uh thing then just 30 minutes ago uh
firsthand from Nicholas uh uh upstairs
uh talking about Opus uh and the amazing
things uh uh with the release of 4.6 six
more than 500 vulnerabilities things
like grow ghost script and uh cjif and
open sc now he spoke about Linux kernel
as well uh so really interesting stuff
and for us we have been sort of driving
isle uh has been driving kind of similar
research and kind of building the
scaffolding and the technology for that
as well even though I have to say for us
it's been a bit of a like a um almost
like incidental type of thing we are a
young company. We only started about a
year ago and the original thesis was
somewhat different. The original thesis
is that we would build a
automatic or agentic remediation tool so
that we wouldn't do any discovery. We
wouldn't do any scanning. We would
ingest all the scanner outputs and uh we
kind of started playing with you know
trying to benchmark the existing
scanners try to find out which scanners
are actually good. So we went back all
open source like 100,000 historical
CVEes and started looking up the
historical vulnerable pieces of code and
by running scanners like the commercial
pattern matching scanners across those
and to our complete shock the efficacy
of those scanners were close to zero. So
even the historical vulnerabilities have
been known that all these signaturebased
scanners could have been taught on or
trained on. Basically it was low
singledigit percentage uh success rates.
And so we started building experimenting
with our own scanner that could find
those mo vulnerabilities. But one thing
started to happen very remarkably that
not only that our LM based approach
could now find vulnerabilities that we
were looking for that is those
historical ones the kind of gold ones as
we call them but he actually started
identifying new vulnerabilities as well
and that's really how we got into this
and we started reporting them and of
course you know it is just um I mean the
this the OpenSSL stuff was just tip of
the iceberg like we started this program
call it August September last year so
it's like six months ago and uh to date
we have also coincidentally same number
as anthropic 500 vulnerabilities that we
confirmed with the uh with the
open-source um maintainers and that
already resulted to about 130 133 uh
CVEes that got issued for us and it's
like a trailing metric so that number is
kind of continuing to increase and again
like very similar trajectory I think
that we have. Now I would like to hand
it over to Adam who is our AI researcher
who will actually tell you a bit more
about the findings themselves and also
how our engine works kind of under the
hood.
>> Yeah, thank you. Yeah. Hi, I'm Adam.
I'll just walk through some of the CVS
we found and why they're interesting. So
I'm going to start with the most serious
one we found in OpenSSL.
This is a stack overflow in a component
of the library that's often used in
email clients. Um, basically the
attacker can control the length of uh
some field in um a uh data notation and
cause a stack buffer overflow. Of
course, there is other protections
usually against uh this causing uh
remote code execution, but OpenSSL is so
widely deployed in so many different
context that this is still a high
severity uh vulnerability um and pretty
sophisticated one. Uh we also have a V
in each browser engine. Uh so Chromium,
Firefox and WebKit.
Um here's an interesting one in traffic.
Um that's a configuration flag in some
Kubernetes deployment where traffic
steps in uh for engineext as the ingress
controller. And here I have the
screenshot of the vulnerability. I have
it here because think it shows why um a
pattern matching scanner would never
find this. So um you can look at it and
maybe spot it yourself. Um I'm going to
give you a few more hints. So basically
the vulnerability is in some flag uh
meant to turn on uh TLS authentication
of the back end behind the Kubernetes
ingress controller. Um but it actually
turns it off. Um can you see it? I don't
know this is go code but like basically
this here says like insecure skip
something something and then here this
part says like if the flag if a flag
called proxy SSL verify is on then this
is true and verify is actually skipped.
So um this is an interesting example of
what LM can notice. Um, here's something
from a different bucket. We've also
jumped on some new projects and started
scanning OpenClaw. We've had over 34
vols in it and this makes us one of the
most active security contributors to it
and stay tuned for some more news about
that. So, wrapping up, um, we blog about
these a lot. We've published almost 20
blog posts. So you can check our website
and our CV hub with all the published
vulnerabilities
and um I'm going to hand it over to
Andre. Yeah. Yeah. What one thing that
uh we kind of are very very sensitive
about and I kind of we learned the hard
way in the beginning is that uh
especially with open source there's this
fine balance between sort of being
useful but not really adding work to
those already overworked people who you
know do this basically in their free
time or many times like very very low
budget. Uh and so really kind of this
notion of AI slob that is you know
having uh AI reports that not only may
be false positive but surely even if
they are not false positive positives
they can add work to those people
meaning that they have to actually uh do
the triaging do the fixing do some
somehow testing etc. So we really always
try to kind of supply the uh the the
maintainers with all the contextual
information and everything that they
need including the fix itself. And like
one example that I would give you is
that uh uh this is from curl. So Daniel
Sternberg who is the original author of
curl very active person in the open
source community uh has been blogging
constantly about AI slop and about this
terrible thing that's happening and like
what I love to see is that Daniel over
the last six months uh because I think
of the kind of report that he's getting
from isle has turned from a complete
kind of skeptic and naysayer to AI uh to
a huge huge fan and to someone who kind
of goes to conferences and talks about
this publicly like he just kind of last
month he was at Fosdam uh which is the
large open source conference he spoke
about uh you know feeling like magic so
you kind of have these people who kind
of traditional hardcore engineers who
have been kind of spending most of their
time writing code manual triaging
vulnerabilities now really you know
preaching the capabilities of the LLM
and really jumping on that bandwagon
which I think is super super cool and
important.
So how do we actually achieve this? Uh
how does find all these vulnerabilities
and achieve such a low false positive
rate? Um the answer is we use a kind of
uh multi-stage progressive refinement
agentic pipeline where each stage acts
as a sift to let through only like real
CV grade findings that could uh cause
real damage and the general approach
could be summarized as having a breath
first broadening phase and a second
focus narrowing phase. So at the start
we let the system generate as many ideas
and hypothesis as possible for what
could be wrong in such and such code.
And here we found that the intrinsic
knowledge and reasoning of the
state-of-the-art models or at least in
the last 6 months sort of aligned with
what Nicholas just said upstairs. U we
find that there are enough to notice
quite deep and sophisticated
vulnerabilities.
Um once we have a lead we double down
and do an agentic exploration of the
potential issue. So this includes trying
to run the code, craft the P fuzzing if
applicable and so on. And here we try to
be really critical and discerning
um using multiple models to assess each
other, come up with different
explanations, look at the issue from
different angles. Um
and uh this essentially emulates the
scenario where you would have a
dedicated team of security engineers
looking at the issue with different
background skills and knowledge
um and generating some informed
consensus and this helps us uh fight
against hallucinations and secancy.
Um, so to get this agentic pipeline to
work well, you need to get many things
right. And a lot of these might seem
like little tricks from an engineering
perspective, but it's an important it's
important to realize that together they
compound into a system that works much
better overall. So some of these ideas
are um heavy parallelism. Humans are
mostly singlethreaded. LLMs or AI agents
don't suffer from this limitation. So
you can run lots and lots of them in
parallel to investigate many many
hypotheses at the same time. Um careful
context construction of course throwing
random stuff into inference doesn't
usually work well. So we try to make
sure that with each subsequent phase we
get a better and better understanding of
the codebase and provide the LLMs with a
heavily optimized context or prompt to
make good judgments and decisions.
Um we still have human in the loop
especially in the final submission phase
though more and more we find that this
is kind of a formal check and the
findings are almost always ready to go.
But I'm mentioning this because this is
still an important thing to do since it
lets you notice potential room for
improvements and align the system to uh
human needs. Um, we're also
experimenting with some specialized
fine-tuned models and doing some
research on the boundary of model
interpretability, robustness and
continual learning. And last but not
least, it's important to have a good
agentic platform, a good base. Uh, so
this includes uh secure and robust
sandbox runtimes, durable execution,
evals, of course, evals are very
important. um observatively same idea
tests and so on.
Um so overall I would say we're more LM
heavy um perhaps contrary to the more
verification or evouse focus we heard
this morning from Google and meta. Uh
and we're basically making a bet that
these models are going to get better and
better and their context windows are
going to get larger and larger in the
future. Though of course we'll probably
still live for some time in a world
where the largest code bases don't fit
into the context window of the model. So
we think there's still a lot of alpha
left in just doing context engineering
really well uh combined with the hard
and soft verifications uh that I
mentioned earlier.
Now most of the work that we have done
so far has been really focused on uh the
open source community uh the free open
source community and like uh we also
very much realized that um you know one
thing is having a super powerful engine
that is uh especially for detection but
ideally for that whole kind of chain of
detection triaging
fixing and verification. Uh the other is
like the entire call it user interface
uh that the human machine interface that
uh you know comes with that and that is
actually becoming you know
many times either like the winning
factor for these kind of solutions or
also the impediment for from being
deployed. So really try to sort of work
with those open source maintainers very
very closely to make sure that whatever
they are getting from us uh is is kind
of fits their needs and it kind of takes
two forms that is uh the number one
thing is the deep scan of the existing
code base obviously. So doing that uh
analysis of historical legacy code that
finding kind of vulnerabilities that
have been buried typically for many
years or decades uh and helping to fix
those. Uh so all the CVEEs that we have
the 500 findings etc these would be in
this category and we obviously continue
doing that. uh but uh also important or
equally as important is to actually keep
new code or new changes uh safe and
secure and so uh that I think is a
slightly different ballgame uh
especially now with AI generated code
that is the amount of code that's being
added or modified in those repos is u
very very large and so being there on
time before the code actually makes it
into prod is super important important.
Uh so I'm happy to say that we've got
this uh for us the primary UX is the
GitHub bot which we have supplied and is
in active usage by some of the ultra
high pro high prominence uh open source
projects uh such as obviously open
opensl itself uh but also open claw as
we spoke about so open claw each and
every PR that gets generated is now
being checked by isle also open EMR
which healthcare uh Apache uh the stuff
that you know not just the server but
that entire ecosystem etc. So that's
really important and we are getting some
you know very strong feedback on that.
Uh so Matt Caswell is the CEO of the
open SSL foundation. Uh so you know very
very strong this case impressed by the
catch and like it always obviously is is
nice to see uh for us. Uh we also
besides the work with open source we now
sort of um you know created a product
that can be used by proprietary code as
well. Uh so as of today actually we uh
launched a this bot is now available for
general public. So if you'd like to just
head to al.com you can check it out
yourself. So um to wrap it up I would
just uh echo what was said multiple
times today already which is we are now
at stage where AI can really find deep
security vulnerabilities
and uh even in those kind of very
hardened security audited pieces of code
but there is this very fragile
equilibrium between the defensive and
offensive side because it's always good
to keep in mind that the bad guys the
bad actors have access to that same
technology as well or even more so so
they can be even more tokenheavy. They
typically especially the nation state uh
actors have almost unlimited resources
when it comes to things like that and it
is already being uh weaponized. So I
think the call to action for all of us
who kind of operate either open source
or uh proprietary code is to really
treat this with maximum urgency. Uh
because we only prevent that what was
called the vulner apocalypse uh multiple
times today. It's a new word that I
learned today. Uh if we move with
urgency and move very fast to really
preempt the bad guys from exploiting
those vulnerabilities. Uh so uh with
that I would like to open it for
question. Thank you for attention.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah. Great talk. Um I've got a
question. So when you said it found 500
um CVE, were those like previously
reported CVES or were those new ones
that you guys found? totally new uh yeah
so it's it's 500 vulnerabilities out of
which we have about 130 minted CVEes but
this is like a trailing indicator
because as you know CVS typically take
months uh to be issued and sometimes
never because of the backlog I think it
was someone said 30,000 uh things in the
backlog before you kind of and it's kind
of first in first out many times.
>> Yeah. Okay. Cool. Cool. Yeah. Sweet.
Thank you.
>> Anybody else
>> Mr. Carl?
>> Yeah. So if you're going to participate
in finding CVEES at that scale, do you
think it makes sense to actually
participate as a CNA in the process? And
kind of the second part of this question
is I think if you talk to most VR people
most of them will agree that CVSS is
kind of a joke in terms of the scoring
is associated mostly for um that's a
harsh terminology but the scoring is
mostly for the defenders who have
specific guidelines on when they need to
remediate this issue. Um right criticals
need to be fixed in an hour in two days
whatever. Um so they constantly push the
scores down. My real question is like
for isle have you considered an
additional scoring system where it's
like this is actually the most important
thing right when you talk about 12 bugs
in OpenSSL of those I think 10 of them
were low severity mostly just crashes so
like does that make sense uh where we
need to evolve into a new form of kind
of scoring these and who is in charge of
that? Yeah. Um, great question. So, so
first of all, CNA, um, yes, uh, we will
likely become a CNA shortly. So, we're
working on that already. Obviously, with
this volume, it makes total sense, uh,
to expedite. Uh, your question about
CBSS, I think it's a very explosive
topic. Uh, we have CBSS3, we have CBSS4.
I think there've been a lot of effort in
making CBSS4 much more robust. uh surely
it has deficiencies
uh but what we like about it is that it
takes into account context uh which
obvious so you can't really establish
CVSS for as a baseline because it kind
of depends where the code's deployed or
like what kind of data it's processing
etc. So um we do have some ideas how to
sort of augment or enrich the scoring
system as well. At the same time we kind
of take this as a even though that the
standard may not be the optimal standard
it is a standard still so people
understand that kind of work in their
work. So um we'll see how that evolves
like we've got some opinions how these
things could like I'm not sure whether
you are also involved in that but like
we would love to perhaps team up with
other people who are somehow you know
digging into this and uh hopefully we
can find something like um like we we
don't want to do it ourselves but if
there is enough momentum coming out of
the community then I think it's
definitely worth revisiting.
All right. Thank you very much,
gentlemen. That was
>> Thank you. Thank you.